[Music]
well hello dear friends uh thank you so
much for joining us uh today for I'd
like to know our question and answer
program uh this is one of our favorite
programs here at Secrets unsealed in
some TV uh because it actually forces us
to do a lot of research to try and find
answers that are based upon God's word
and the spirit of Prophecy uh I'd like
to give you the email address where you
can send us your questions you'll see it
on the screen TVM tv.org once again TVM
tv.org we'd be delighted to get your
questions any question is valid no
question is off limits um many questions
we might not be able to find an answer
for because there are Mysteries there
are things that God has not revealed uh
maybe someday he will reveal to the them
to us in the Kingdom but if we can find
an answer we will do our best to do so I
have with me Pastor David Salazar uh who
is in charge of our Spanish work he's
the CEO of our Spanish work here at
Secrets unsealed among other things and
it's always a joy to work with him he
always has this nice smile on his face
not only in the program but also as he
walks down the hall thank you so much
for being with us and would you have
prayer for us absolutely Pastor let us
pray Heavenly Father Lord as we come
before you once again to seek your
throne of grace we thank you for giving
us the opportunity to come before you
and to ask humbly for the holy spirit
that it will be our teacher our guide
the one that will help us answer the
questions according to your will so we
pray Lord that you will put in us that
uh portion of the holy spirit so that we
may answer and the questions may be uh
given a clear response so that the those
that are seeking truth may find it and
be pointed to Christ to you the source
of all wisdom and Glory I thank you for
your blessings we pray all of these in
Jesus name amen amen amen well we'll
begin with this very interesting
question I have seen this question
before mhm um it's this is it biblically
correct as an Adventist to attend a
family funeral on Sabbath so what can we
say about that good question pastor and
I think that uh maybe the question or
the answer biblically we can say that
Christ for example he died on Friday and
he was buried on Friday evening or or
Friday before the sunset because of the
rules that they had imposed upon the
strict rules of how to keep the Sabbath
and Christ was not one
to uh create a diversion or or trying to
establish some sort of rebelling to the
established set of rules but it was not
necessarily because it was wrong to bury
somebody on the Sabbath day it was
mainly according to the uh restrictions
that the Pharisees had placed obviously
what we can do besid the Sabbath is to
be done so but somebody for example that
that's very dear to our faith El G white
she died on Friday she died actually
Friday July 16
1915 which was a Friday afternoon I
actually have had the privilege to go to
elm's Haven where she died and in the
location where she died there was
actually a clock and they stopped up the
clock at the moment or the hour that she
died Wednesday afternoon so the funeral
services and and and remember that
funeral is not necessarily the bearing
ceremony but the funeral service for
Ellen White was done on July
18th and in there in Els Haven then
which is a Sunday then July 19th if I
don't mistaken was in Richmond which is
also in California where many people
were able to come and gather but the
main or the biggest of her funerals
which was a third funeral was done on
July
24th in Battle Creek now July 24th is a
Saturday was a Sabbath day and there's a
picture and you can actually see through
our you know Pioneer books and things of
that you know of that sort where you can
see the pictures of her funeral and
thousands of people gathered there was a
big you know group of people who had
come from many far and wide to to kind
of be present at that funeral service so
our Prophet the servant of the Lord
was put in funeral on a Sabbath I don't
see necessarily A a mistake of attending
a funeral service on the Sabbath day as
a matter of fact I had to even conduct c
a couple of times of funeral services on
a Sabbath for for for being the only
time that was possible for the family to
do so I don't see is a mistake and I
think that I know that some people like
I said might be afraid of breaking the
Sabbath day for going to a funeral but a
funeral can be actually an opportunity
to share the place at Hope with those
that are not of the faith you know for
family members to know that you believe
in the coming of Christ so it can be a
actual moment of testifying about who
the Lord is and why we we don't have to
worry or to feel hopeless as we believe
in the second coming of Christ yeah and
it's very very common to have memorial
service is on Sabbath right almost every
memorial service that I've ever seen is
held on Sabbath right you know they
don't have the casket there with with a
person in it but um they have pictures
you know of the person they do a little
bio on the screen and so on uh so uh
nothing per se wrong with having a
funeral service on Sabbath you can make
a call to the family right that have not
committed their lives to the Lord you
know it's a perfect time to do it
because people see they mortality right
and uh and so um the answer to this
question I believe uh is uh no uh it's
not wrong to have a funeral on Sabbath
uh there are other things that would be
wrong the question does not ask about
weddings on Sabbath you know if you have
a simple wedding where you declare them
men and wife that's one thing but with a
wedding you have all kinds of
preparations you have the dressing up
and you have you know the putting on the
makeup if the people use the makeup and
you know they have to prepare for the
reception and there's just a lot of
things that are not uh Sabbath
activities but funeral I don't see any
issue absolutely and again if the person
that is invited to uh these funeral
services you know may have a question
like is a funeral some cultures have
celebrations have music have things of
that nature um I could understand maybe
some some sort of uh hesitancy to be
able to be part of that but I believe
that if it's a a service where it can be
uh like as you said possibility to share
with others about the love of the Lord
and the promise of Salvation and and of
his second coming I think it's a great
opportunity to share and to present the
truth to those that are not you know of
the faith yeah I think the case of
Christ uh you know being buried before
the Sabbath um I think that case is
perhaps unique uh because uh Jesus had
to rest in the Tomb every single minute
of the Sabbath because he was resting
from his works of redemption you know on
the cross he said it is finished he died
and then he was buried shortly before
Sundown right because he had to rest in
the Tomb 24 hours like he had done at
creation right but uh you know with
human beings there's not that particular
need right because uh you know we're not
redeemers right no so um so I think in
the case of Christ is perhaps a little
different than uh than generally
everybody else
absolutely okay so let's go to our next
question uh this one comes from uh Liza
or Lisa uh from Ontario Canada and um
I'll read it and then I'll uh I'll throw
it over to you sure sure good afternoon
my dear brothers
I I pray all is well with you and with
all your families I hold your ministry
very valuable in my life and the world
especially in the times we are living
you are all in my prayers my name is
Alisa it says at the top Lisa but is now
it says Alisa I live in Ontario Canada I
have a question about the Tree of Life
where in the Bible does say the tree of
life was taken back to Heaven I believe
that Ellen White says it was taken back
to Heaven Before the Flood also is there
more than one tree of life one on earth
and another in heaven I believe there is
one tree but some brethren say it was
replicated here on Earth which is the
truth thank you Pastor that's an
interesting question and I'm glad that
our friend
Lisa uh ascends this question first of
all from the word of God in Revelation
2:7 we hear or we read the following is
a promise of God to the first church the
church of Ephesus and he says the
following to him that overcometh will I
give to eat of the tree of life which is
in the midst of the paradise of God so
here we know that Christ himself as he
speaks his promise and he gives this
beautiful promise to those that overcome
that they will take of that tree of life
which is in the midst of the priz of God
now then of course we know that uh in
the end of Revelation also 20 chapter 21
we know that he again sees the Tree of
Life there and we need to now know is
this the tree of life that was in the
Garden of Eden well the spirit prophecy
makes it very clear C that it is that is
the same tree or or that is in the or
that the tree that was in the Garden of
Eden was also or is also the tree in the
new heaven uh I will read from the book
maratha page 354 there's a several U
quotes there that kind of gives us an an
overview of what Christ of what Al White
saw in in heaven and it says there uh
beginning at the very top of the day of
the of the quote here it says the Garden
of Eden remain upon the Earth long after
the man had become an outcast from its
pleasant paths so in other words the
Garden of Eden stayed even though they
were expelled from the from Adam and Eve
from the garden they they stay there
they are the garden stay here in Earth
now here um says when the tide of
iniquity overspread the world and the
wickedness of men determined their
destruction by a flood of waters he or
the hand that had planted Eden withdrew
it from the earth so God took that
Garden of Eden but in the final
restitution when there shall be a new
Heaven and a new Earth it is to be
restored more gloriously adorned than at
the beginning now she mentions there
that when she sees in Vision at the end
or at the beginning at the end of the
the um at the end of the whole process
of Destruction and the redeem in in
heaven she mentions there Adam is
speaking of Adam Adam is reinstated in
his first Dominion transported with joy
he beholds the trees that were once his
Delight the very trees whose fruit he
himself had gathered in the days of his
innocence and joy he sees the vines that
his own hands have trained the very
flowers that he once Lov to care for his
mind grasp the reality of the scene he
comprehends that this is indeed inde
Eden restored and restored to the tree
of life is the long lost Eden the
Redeemer will grow up to the full statue
of the race in his primeval Glory the
last lineage of the traces of the curse
of sin will be removed and Christ
faithful ones will appear in the beauty
of the Lord Our God in the mind and soul
and body reflected the perfect image of
either Lord oh wonderful Redemption long
take it off long hope for contemplated
with eager anticipation but never fully
understood so she here again connects
the fact that the Tree of Life which was
in the Garden of Eden was is the same
tree of life that we are taking at the
restoration of all things when we are in
heaven the very same Garden of Eden that
Adam worked with the same trees the same
Vines she mentions are the same vines
that are again he has access to so is
the same Tree of Life yes God took it
away with the G of leing Before the
Flood and he left it in the the paradise
and the same tree of life that we will
partake of at the very end there's
biblical
proof that the Garden of Eden was in
heaven before it came to the
Earth in Ezekiel
28 it's talking about um
Lucifer and uh in his in his original
condition before sin in verse 12 it says
son of man take up a lamentation for the
king of Ty who is a type of of Lucifer
and say to him thus says the Lord God
you were the Seal of perfection full of
wisdom and perfect in Beauty you were in
Eden the Garden of
God every precious stone was your
covering the sardus topaz and Diamond
Burl onx and Jasper Sapphire turquoise
an emerald with gold the workmanship of
your timal and pipes was prepared for
you on the day that you were
created so it says you were in Eden the
Garden of God before he sinned right
which means that the Garden of Eden that
was on Earth was transplanted from
Heaven to Earth right and after the
flood there is no Garden of Eden I don't
know of any place on Earth where the
Garden of Eden is so it must be in
heaven right so what Ellen White says
always makes perfect sense amen you know
where does the bible say that you know
people always ask like they're doubting
in the spirit of Prophecy if you look
hard enough you're going to find that
what Ellen White says is contained in
the Bible amen amen all right pastor we
have another question read that one
question it says from
Jose and he says hello sutv since God is
the only Immortal being and all created
beings are relying their immortality on
God how come Satan is still alive since
Satan is no longer in the presence of
God thank
you it's a good it's a good question but
uh do we really have an
answer well for one thing we don't have
immortality right I mean so yes I I
think that's what he's trying to say
that you know if we were to gain
immortality H it's only when we are
saved when we are redeemed and God will
you know bestow upon us that that new
body and new experience
but why is Satan not Al liive or alive
uh because he's no longer person of God
that's a I think it's a question that we
sort of find the answer in the Bible in
the sense that God allowed Satan to
develop the the aspect of sin fully so
that not only us in our experience of of
of rebellion or or great controversy we
understand what sin does but the whole
universe so that the whole universe
could see the results of sin so in his
Mercy the Lord did not destroy Satan
right away yeah did not cut off his life
but he had to allowed the enemy to fully
develop what sin would really bring to
the universe so that no one could have a
question or the doubt why this way of
sin is death and why the way of the Lord
is life so I think in mercy God has
granted him time but I don't think it's
because uh there is a real um you know
biological reason why he's alive still
you know I think it's just mercy of God
in allowing sin to fully be developed
for the sake of his own uh character in
a sense yeah um you know God gives each
creature a certain constitutional force
with us it depends on our ancestors as
well how much the better power has been
used by our ancestors we don't know how
much vital force God gave to the angels
because that's not only Satan that's
right who who's been alive for the last
6,000 years his angels too there's no
reference to any of his angels dying
that's true so you know and this we
don't have a thus sayith the Lord for
this right U we can only may make
calculated guesses that perhaps God gave
Satan uh Lucifer a much uh more
longlasting vital force than what he
gave Adam and Eve in the Garden of Eden
and that's why he's continued uh to live
but if if time
continued
eventually the Constitutional force of
Satan and his angels would
also die right because they are not
Immortal they their life still depends
on the vital for course that God gave
them and So eventually if uh if God
decided just to Simply let evil run its
course Satan and his angels would cease
to
exist uh so did God does God keep Satan
alive to reveal Satan's Plan before the
Universe I believe so yeah but is it
because God gave him a much greater
constitutional Force than he gave Adam
and Eve that's what we don't know for
sure
one thing that we know for sure he's
going to be
toast he's going to be destroyed he's
going to be he's going to cease to exist
along with all of his cohorts the angels
that fell with him as well as all the
wicked and then God is going to make a
new heavens and a new Earth and we will
have to continue eating from the Tree of
Life on a regular basis every month to
recharge our battery amen amen and you
know pastors mention it is true that the
enemy you know the Satan Ellen White
mentions that he has lost much of his
Beauty much of his yes uh aspect of of
of Holiness that he had before the fall
so definitely there's there is a winding
down if you will of his own life but as
you mentioned God will destroy him he's
not goingon to expire because he's
battery just expired but God will
destroy the enemy along with all his the
angel ual and those of course who have
been lost um so that's an interesting
question uh we have a I think time for
one more question that's from Frank and
from Wilton Maine and the question is my
wife and I recently started receiving
Social Security our question is since we
pay tithe on our gross income including
Social Security during our working years
should we tithe now on our monthly
payments I am thinking no but I would
like another perspective it's a could
question Pastor God doesn't charge us a
second
tithe the bottom line is that say a
person for 40
years has has actually um paid Social
Security
okay uh until
retirement they are not reaping benefits
from Social Security so there has been
no increase so do they have to do they
have to tithe their social security
check when they start receiving the
benefits um they would have to calculate
how much they put into Social
Security so it becomes complicated but
there's a simple solution to the problem
I ties everything you can you can't
outgive the Lord exactly you know I not
only I not only tithe my
gross including the money that went to
Social
Security but you know I tithe now that
I'm benefiting from Social Security um
it's better to be safe than sorry yes
right you going to rub God yeah so so
you know um why not just go ahead and
tithe or else you have to be calcul well
how much did I put in during 40 years
and then I'll you know I'll tithe until
the moment when uh when we get to the
point where um there's there's no more
there's no more equal social security uh
that I put in and how much I got back so
it's just best to to tithe both but
technically speaking I think that uh you
God does not expect you to
tithe that which you have not re
received an increase or a benefit from
until you start reaping those benefits
and so if if you treat it as an income
and it sustains you uh you know like you
said it's better to be be on a safer
ground and and and if you have that
income and it's for you to live uh put
trust in the Lord I believe God will
multiply whatever is left sometimes we
get worried and I understand you know
the concern maybe they thinking bills or
health bills or something that may
happen but if you put that relationship
of trust in God he is saying you know if
you trust me with your tithes and
offerings you will know that I will open
the Winds of heaven so I think there's
much more of a invitation to trust God
with him providing for us and like you
said we can never out give to the Lord
you know when I was uh working in the
denomination um I had to set aside
quarterly payments I had to send in
quarterly payments for social
security um so my
check did not discount social security
mhm uh the conference didn't so you know
I just basically paid tithe on the whole
income you know and and I'm glad I did
because you know the tithe goes to help
the proclamation of the gospel and uh
you know there's nothing wrong with
giving a double tithe though doesn't
require it but there's nothing wrong
with it it just helps carry the gospel
to the world amen amen well I don't
think we have time for another question
time is winding down and uh we want to
thank you once again for tuning in to
this program please send us your
questions uh we long to do the research
to answer them according to the Bible
and the spirit of Prophecy uh once again
may God bless you keep you in his care
remember to study your Bible remember to
sing his praises and to pray God bless
you hope to see you next
time
[Music]